Bitte schön.
Hallo Guten Tag.
Ich bin auf dieser Session als Assistenzart tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Autonomiegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, hallo schon, guten Tag. Ja, gerne.
Ja, ich will Ihre persönlichen Angaben fragen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Walter Schmidt.
Ja, genau.
Das ist Ende DT?
Ja, Ende mit DT, ja genau.
Okay. Herr Schmidt, ja?
Ja, genau.
Herr Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
60 Jahre alt, okay.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Das ist den 1.4.
Ja.
1962.
Sie war dann 60.
Genau.
Herr Schmidt, wie groß sind Sie?
180.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
90.
90 kg.
Ja.
Herr Schmidt, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Was können Sie mich tun?
Ich bin hier, weil ich seit ungefähr 1 Woche so eine Wechselhaft-Uberbauchschmessen habe
und ab und zu sehr stark.
Als Sie gesagt haben, ich kann das nicht genau nachvollziehen,
wann die Schmerzattacke auftreten.
Und was ich noch gemerkt habe,
dass ich so ein leicht schwarzes Studiengang auf habe.
Schwarze Studiengang.
Genau.
Sie haben gesagt, ja, seit ungefähr 1 Woche Bauchschmessen, ja?
Ja, so eine Oberbauchschmessen, genau.
Ein gesamter Bauch würde ich nicht sagen,
sondern eher Oberbauchschmessen.
Und Sie haben schwarze Studiengang, ja?
Einmal habe ich gesehen, das war gestern.
Einmal.
Das hat mich natürlich Gedanken gemacht,
und habe gesagt, ich gehe mal aus der Skange raus.
Okay.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe eine Schmerzattacke,
die ich in der Schmerzattacke habe.
Okay.
Wie viel?
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe eine Schmerzattacke,
die ich in der Schmerzattacke habe.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Als Sie gesagt haben, wenn ich den Attacke bekomme,
so eine Schmerzattacke,
so eine Druckgefühl, so eine Brinnen auch.
Ich würde sagen, so eine Brinnengefühl.
Okay.
Ja.
Ja, so Brinnen, nicht Brinnen, Brinnen,
sondern als etwas Brind drin.
Ja, auch Brinnen, okay, Brinnen.
Ja, okay.
Als Sie gesagt haben, ja,
so eine Druckgefühl habe ich schon,
sondern auch außerhalb der Schmerz,
ich habe so eine Druckgefühl im Oberbord,
als ich es zu einem Verdauungsproblem habe.
Ja.
Also wenn man esst und so eine volle Gefühle mag,
und diese Gefühle habe ich immer noch.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Druckgefühl und Brinnengefühl, ja?
Ja, Brinnengefühl ist als eher bei Schmerzattacke,
und so eine volle Gefühle ist so ein fast dauerhaft.
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Wie war das mit der Schmerz?
Die Schmerz begann eigentlich vor einer Woche,
ungefähr, sind langsam,
am Anfang so war es so dumpf,
ein bisschen Druckgefühl,
war nicht so stark,
und im Verlauf hat sich natürlich intensiviert.
Und seit drei Tagen
habe ich den Brinnengefühl auch,
und ja, dieser Druckgefühl ist immer da.
Okay.
Ich habe gesagt,
ein Reichswahrs- und Stuhlgang, ja?
Okay.
Das ist Oberbauchschmerz.
Ihr Apathet verändert,
oder?
Ja, ich habe gesagt,
ich habe gesagt,
ihr Apathet verandert oder
wie ist mit dem Appetit, meinen Sie es?
Ja, ihr Appetit
seit einer Woche gut oder verschlechtert.
Ja.
Aber Sie können auch so freuen,
wie sieht es mit der Appetit aus?
Haben Sie Appetit oder haben Sie Appetitlosigkeit?
Okay.
Sie können das auch so formulieren, ja?
Eine einfache Frage.
Appetit haben sie Appetitlosigkeit oder ist es gleichgeblieben? Ich versuche es einfach so
so so sagen einfacher formulieren für sich. Okay, ein Anfussig Appetitlosigkeit habe ich nicht,
aber ich habe so ein voller Gefühl, ja? Ich will essen, aber sobald ich etwas esse,
ich fühle mich sehr einfach, weil ich einfach so eine große Prostierung gegessen habe,
obwohl ich nach drei, vier Löffel schon dieser volle Gefühl bekomme. Okay.
Okay. Machen wir folgens, als ich im Nut auf Neurwien, dass in der Turkei eine Präzent auf
die Neurwien, die Stenarzt, die Wälder, wie gehen sie vor mit denen? Also fühlen sich ganz
bequem, locker und stellen sie ihre Frage einfach, wie sie einfach so ein tachlich richtig finden.
Okay. Okay. Ihr konntet alles verstanden,
ich habe es so gesagt.
Ja, Sie haben schwarze Stullgang gehabt. Wie war das? Das war und das ist sehr flüssig oder dünn
für Sie, Konsistenz Ihrer Stullgang. Ich meine die Konsistenz Ihrer Stullgang. Ja.
Ja, gute Frage. Ich würde sagen, anfussig, es war ganz normal, ja? Es war wieder wisserig noch
herrhardt, es war noch ganz normales Stullgang, aber so ein Schwarz von der Farbe, ja?
Ja. Und das hat mich natürlich bisschen krank gemacht.
Es ist ja wieder sehr flüssig.
Okay.
Okay. Ganz normales Stullgang.
Ja, das wird dann auch wieder gelöst.
Hallo.
Ja, tanze mich.
Ja, ich höre, ja, okay.
Wir waren bei, wie ich. Ja, genau, jetzt gehen Sie los.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe Sie Ihre Tolerate, Gewöhnlichkeit verändert, zum Beispiel.
Häufige oder zeltene geworden?
Ich verändere mich, die Hand für Sie hat sich nicht geändert. Ich gehe wie immer,
ein, zwei Mal pro Tag, manchmal drei Mal.
Ja, das ist eine Frage, bestimmt geht es um, ob ich Verstoffung habe oder
Erdurchfall. Ich habe wieder Verstoffung, noch Durchfall.
Ja, haben Sie Verstoffung oder Durchfall?
Nein, ich habe wieder Verstoffung, noch Durchfall. Das heißt,
der Stullgang an für sich ist normal.
Verstoffung und Durchfall, ja?
Nein.
Wieder Verstoffung, noch Durchfall, das heißt, keine von dir weiter.
Okay, okay, ganz normal durchfall.
Ganz normal durchfall, genau.
Okay.
Wie stark Ihre Bauchschmerzen auf einer Schmerzschmerzskala 1 ist,
sehr leichter Schmerz, 10 ist unerträglicher Schmerz entspricht.
Okay, wie stark ist Ihre Bauchschmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerzschkala zwischen 0 bis 1, wenn man 0 keine Schmerzen
bezeichnet und 10 starke Schmerzen, wo man nicht durchhalten kann.
Während der Schmerzattacker habe ich eine Schmerzschkala von
ungefähr 8 bis 9, aber kontinuierlich habe ich dann
ungefähr so eine dunkelte Druckgefühl, das ist auch unangenehm.
Das ist wie Schmerzen, ja?
Das ist zwischen 1 bis 2, ja?
Als ich Schmerzen habe, habe ich so eine dunkelte Druckgefühl.
Aus einer Schmerzattack 2 oder 3, ja?
Ja, aus der Schmerzattackerzeitraum ist zwischen 2 bis 3,
während Schmerzattackerzeitraum ist bis 8 und 9.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber gefüllt?
Auf ich Fiebe, haben Sie Fieber gehabt oder hatten Sie Fieber
oder haben Sie Hoch-Tampardu gemeint?
Ja, hatten Sie Fieber.
Ja, ich habe es leider nicht gemessen, aber mir war etwas warm,
aber jeder voraus, das war keine Fieber.
Das ist durch Schmerzattacker, natürlich hat man ab und zu
natürlich so eine andere Gefühl, so ein warmes Gefühl,
aber richtig Fieber habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay, okay.
Was lassen?
Wie ist es mit dem Wasen lassen?
Eigentlich haben für sich normal.
Okay, was lassen?
Okay.
Und okay.
Ich möchte noch fragen,
haben Sie Üblichkeit gehabt?
Leicht ja.
Eigentlich, seit gestern habe ich etwas Übelkeit,
so leichte Übelkeit.
Ich habe zu Hause Medikamente gehabt, die ich von meiner Frau war
und davon habe ich schon einen Stück genommen.
Das hat nicht geholfen.
Okay, welche Arzneimittel haben Sie eingenommen?
Dann haben Sie die Arzneimittel geholfen.
Ja, das heißt MCP, steht drauf auf dem By-Pack-Sitzel.
Okay, okay.
590 Milligramm, ja?
Nein, so eine 10 Milligramm.
Ah, 7 Milligramm.
Okay, haben Sie Erb-9?
Ne.
Okay.
Und das...
Ich möchte Ihre Vorerkrankung fragen.
Haben Sie Probleme,
wie es bei der Krone,
wie es bei der Brutverzweiflung ist?
Okay, Sie fragen, ob ich eine krone Krankung habe,
ob ich leider unter einer krone Krankung bin.
Das würde ich sagen, nein.
Ich habe mich bisher immer wohlgefühlt.
Ich habe nie krank, nie beim Arzt gewesen.
Mein Blutdruck war immer okay.
Ich habe keine Blutdruck.
Ich habe auch Blutzucker nie gemessen.
Ich habe es auch nicht gebraucht.
Ich habe auch Gewicht und Großheuer
auf den Körper belasten.
Ich mache Sport, ich gehe in Fitness.
Ich mache Jogging und fahren.
Das sind meine Hobbys.
Aber ich war nie krank.
Okay, okay.
Das ist sehr gut.
Okay, haben Sie allergien?
Ob ich eine allergienische Erlegerung habe?
Oder kontraste Erlegerung?
Ob ich allergienische Erlegerung habe,
oder Unverträglichkeit?
Weil allergienische Erlegerung ist anders.
Das muss man unterscheiden.
Ich habe nie auf die Medikamente eingenommen.
Ich habe Kantologie.
Keine Schwierigkeitsmitte.
Unverträglichkeit habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Das ist ein Lebensmittel.
Unverträglichkeit habe ich nicht.
Ich vertrage alles sehr gut.
Okay, sehr gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Ich meine, ein Schlafstörungen oder durch Schlafstörungen?
Eigentlich habe ich bis vor einer Woche alles gut.
Seit einer Woche habe ich ein Problem mit dem Durchschlassen.
Weil ich diese volle Gefühl habe,
dass es im Oberbauchbereich natürlich schon angenehm ist.
Okay.
Aber diese Zeit haben Sie keine Schlafstörungen?
Ich habe keine Schlafstörungen.
Außer dieses Zeitraum.
Bis vor einer Woche war alles okay.
Okay.
Das ist gut.
Sie rauchen?
Nicht mehr.
Seit ungefähr vor 20 Jahren habe ich bis vor 20 Jahren geraucht.
20 Jahre geraucht.
Bis vor 20 Jahren.
Das heißt, Sie wollen gerne wissen, wie lange ich geraucht habe.
Ungefähr 10 Jahre habe ich geraucht.
Zwischen 1990 bis 2000,
das war ungefähr 10 Jahre,
in diesem Zeitraum habe ich geraucht.
Ungefähr 10 bis 15 Sekret pro Tag.
Okay.
Sie haben 10 Jahre geraucht.
Wie viele Zigaretten hatten Sie geraucht?
10 bis 15.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol hervschimit?
Ja, am Wochenende trinke ich gerne.
Mit Freunden sind er 2-3 Gläser Wein
und 1-2 Bier zu sagen.
Bier? Okay.
Am Wochenende, ja.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist die roten Frage.
Hatten Sie Mitdrogenerfahrung gemacht?
Ja, ich habe sie nicht gemacht.
Okay, das ist gut.
Okay.
Nun, es ist eine große Frage.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, sie sind nicht mehr im Leben, sie sind schon tot.
Fast vor 10 Jahren.
Die waren beiden schwer erkrankt sozusagen.
Mein Mutter hatte Lungenkrebs
und mein Vater hatte Darmkrebs.
Okay.
Ja.
Sind Sie vererratet, Herr Schmidt?
Ich war vererratet, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich bin geschrieben.
Okay.
Sie leben allein oder?
Ich lebe allein, ja.
Okay.
Ja, sie sind schon groß.
Ich habe eine Tochter und ein Sohn.
Die beiden sind kein gesund, die haben auch kein Problem.
Okay.
Sie sind ja nicht gesund?
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben so viel Sporttreiben, ja?
Ich kann nicht so viel sagen, aber ich versuche so viel Sporttreiben.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich habe meine alle Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinsetzen?
Ja, ich habe meine alle Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinsetzen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, mir ist etwas schwindelig.
Ich wollte gerne wissen, was mir vorsteht,
was die Planen, wie das aussieht, ob ich hier aufgenommen werden,
ob ich entlassen werden.
Okay, Sie haben schwindelig gesagt, ja?
Ja, Sie haben schwindelig, sagt man nicht.
Sie haben schwindel oder ihr ist schwindelig?
Okay.
Haben Sie schwindel, so fragt man.
Okay. Haben Sie surresal schwindel?
Ja.
Mir sind zwar schwindel, ja genau. Ich habe etwas schwindel.
Okay.
Haben Sie diese ...
...
... wegen dieser Schwindel,
haben Sie ...
hatten Sie früher schwindel gehabt?
Seit ...
außer dieser Zeit?
Ja.
Ob ich, ob schwindel bei mir bekannt ist, ob ich schon mal schwindel gehabt habe,
ich habe nie schwindel gehabt, das ist seit zwei Tagen,
heute ist etwas mehr.
Ich gehe da voraus, es hängt zusammen mit meinem aktuelles Problem.
Okay.
Ich würde hier ein Brutdruck messen.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie wegen dieser ...
Schwindel,
...
beim Laufen,
geschnitten,
...
waren Sie bewusst sein Verlust?
Ob ich, ne, so eine starke Schwindel, wo ich meine ...
... bewusst sein Verlust habe,
könnte, weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe mich nicht gestürzt bisher.
Das ist nur, wenn ich aufstehe schnell, oder wenn ich lange stehen bleibe,
dann ist mir schwindelig.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Ich würde gerne hier ein Brutdruck messen.
Ja.
Ich möchte Sie etwas ...
Hünsüfürgunn oder Fragan an mich?
Als Sie meine Frage gestellt haben,
ich war auf Ihre Entscheidung.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich würde gerne Ihre Köpelchen untersuchen.
Dann würde ich Brut abnehmen.
Dann ...
Dann würde ich wahrscheinlich ...
Bildgebinde ...
Bildgebinde verfahren.
Und ...
dann ...
dann wieder innen sprechen.
Ja.
Alles klar.
Das heißt, Sie werden das entsprechende Teil nennen
und dann mich auch mitteilen, was ich noch ...
zu tun habe, oder was ich noch ...
noch achten müssen.
Ja.
Ich könnte Sie bitte, nehmen Sie bitte Platz.
Ich rufe Ihnen gleich ab, ab, ja, abrufen.
Ich rufe Sie auf Ihren Knauf.
Ja.
Ich habe Kollegen andere Fragen.
Kollegen, Kolleginnen.
Es gibt viele Fragen, die man noch spielen soll.
Ja, ja, viele Fragen aber.
Erst einmal.
Das wurde gefragt, ah ...
Hat der Patient übergelegt in der Prüfung?
Ich habe nicht gehört. Ja.
Ich hatte Übelkeit.
Ich habe etwas dagegen genommen.
Das wurde gefragt und ich habe es beantwortet.
Ja.
Wir haben gesagt, die Schmerzattacke haben.
Wie dauert die Schmerzattacke an und ...
Wie lange dauert das?
Wie lange dauert.
Ja.
Wie oft kommt es zu einer Attacke?
Okay.
Wie oft ich Attacke bekomme und wie lange dauert das?
Ich kann das einfach beantworten.
Die Attacke an sich hält sich mindestens in eine Stunde.
Wenn ich gar nichts einnehme.
Ich muss schon etwas einnehmen gegen Schmerzen.
Und die kommen so eine 2-3-mal-Set gestern.
Das ist nicht so häufig.
Haben Sie diese Schmerzen etwas Medikamenten eingenommen?
Ob ich so eine Schmerzmittel eingenommen habe, das Bild, oder?
Ich habe gesagt, ich muss da einnehmen.
Und das habe ich auch getan.
Ich hatte zu Hause, ich habe immer noch zu Hause in Nowalien.
Und als ich das Gefühl bekam, dass ich die Attacke bekomme,
dann habe ich sofort den Nowalginen eingenommen.
Wie oft einen Tag haben Sie einen?
Seit gestern ungefähr 3-mal pro Tag bis 1000 mg.
Hatten Sie so etwas für die Erschöne einmal?
Ob ich so eine gleiche Symptome habe?
Gleiche Beschwerden habe ich nie gehabt.
Gibt es 500 Tausend Schmerzen?
Grüne Frage, das habe ich nicht genau geachtet.
Aber wenn ich so etwas Alkohol trinke,
dann ist es schlimmer.
Da muss ich mich auf Alkohol verzichten.
Das tue ich auch.
Und ich trinke keine Alkohol, seit ich die Schmerzen habe.
Haben Sie öfter so Blenden oder Zyrus aufgestoßen?
Sie haben gesagt, völlig gefehlt.
Daher haben Sie auch völlig gefehlt.
Die habe ich auch seit längerer Zeit.
Dieser Säureaufstossgefühl habe ich seit längerer Zeit.
Ungefähr seit 2-3 Monaten.
Aber ich habe es nicht geachtet.
Ich habe gedacht, das liegt daran,
dass ich viel trinke oder dass ich auf meiner Ernährung
nicht achte oder Stressbedingungen habe.
Ich habe immer versucht,
die Sachen, die ich im Leben erlebe, zu verkaufen.
Aber ob das stimmt, weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Aber ich habe das so eine Brinnengefühle.
Wenn Sie Bauchschmerzen bekommen,
die Geschichte noch etwas zur Selben sei.
die Geschichte noch etwas zur Selben sei,
die Herzkuloffe von Stolpein im Schweißausbruch.
Ich habe eine andere Erscheinung.
Im Sinne von einer Symptome, die Sie gesählt haben,
muss ich mich überlegen.
Natürlich den Hessrasen habe ich.
Das ist so, wenn ich die Schmerzen habe.
Natürlich muss es normal sein,
dass man Schmerzen hat oder Schmerzen hat.
Dass man diese Panikbefühle bekommt.
Das gehört dazu.
Ansonsten mehr habe ich nicht.
Schmieden und Schmerzen in eine bestimmte Region auf?
Ja, inzwischen beide Schulter.
Wie viele Jahre trinken Sie Alkohol?
Seit wie lange trinken Sie Alkohol?
Seit ungefähr fünf Jahren?
Seit fünf Jahren.
Sie haben erst 1964 gesagt.
Aber Sie haben noch gesagt, siebzig Jahre alt.
Sein Sechs geboren, ich glaube,
sein Sechs macht sechs Jahre.
Nein, sechs Jahre.
Sechs, sechs, zero habe ich gesagt.
Sechs Jahre alt.
Okay.
Wie lange haben Sie sich ab oder zu genommen?
Ob ich in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen habe.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass ich jetzt ungefähr,
kann sein, dass ich jetzt in der letzten Woche mehr darauf geachtet habe.
Ungefähr zwei, drei Kilo abgenommen.
Aber seit wie lange und wie, das kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Haben Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Okay, danke schön.
Das war es.
Das wird Frage schluppt beschweren.
Haben Sie heute manchmal Schwarzveräuern?
Sie haben gesagt, hatten Sie vier?
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben nicht mehr.
Aber so ein Schlupp beschweren wurde auch jetzt gefragt im Gruppe.
Die habe ich auch nicht.
Okay, danke schön.
Als erstes können wir anfangen, Jakub.
Ja, starten wir.
Wenn wir keine Freien, wir haben.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Ja.
Herr Walter Schmidt hat sich wegen
der Corona-Krise im Jahr 2020
in einem Jahr auf die Erhörige zu gehen.
Er hat sich vorgestellt,
dass die Erhörige seit einem Jahr
in einem Jahr auf die Erhörige zu gehen.
Er hatte eine Schwerze Stulgang.
Das war gestern.
Seit drei Tagen hatte er eine volle Gefühl.
Er hatte eine volle Gefühl.
Er hatte eine ganz normale Defokation.
Er strelte seine Schmerz aus.
Er hatte zwei oder drei Schmerzskala-Lege.
Er hatte eine Verbrechung.
Er hatte eine Schmerzskala-Lege.
Er hatte eine leichte Übelkeit.
Er hatte eine sehr leichte Übelkeit.
Er hatte keine Verbrechung.
Er hatte keine Medikamente.
Er hatte eine sehr leichte Übelkeit.
Er hatte zwei oder drei Weine.
Er hatte zwei Beas.